-My next guest is an Oscar- and
Golden Globe-winning director.
He's also produced a new
National Geographic special
called "Secrets of the Whales,"
which premieres tomorrow
on Disney+.
Here is James Cameron!
Yeah! Hey, that's what
I'm talking about.
-Hey.
-It is so good to see you,
buddy. Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
And thank you for coming on.
-It's so great to be
sort of on the show virtually.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, I know.
Exactly, right?
You must be living in kind of
a virtual life now
with the "Avatar 2" and "3,"
right? Everything's virtual.
-Yeah, you're actually visiting
me in my cutting room right now.
I'm down here in
Wellington, New Zealand.
-You're in the bunker there
working on "Avatar 2" and "3."
I can't wait.
You know I'm fan of yours.
And "Avatar" was unlike anything
I've ever experienced
in the movies.
I loved it so much.
And how do you top "Avatar"
with "2" and "3"?
-I cry.
I just sit here at my desk.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-And I cry all day long,
because there's no way.
-Yeah, of course.
-And it's just too much
pressure, dude, you know?
No, look, we just
try to be kind of true
to what people loved
about the first film
and take it into, you know,
whole new areas,
like a lot of our scenes
are in the ocean.
-Oh, really?
-And so I'm combining things
I love, like making "Avatar"
and going into the ocean.
I love all that stuff.
-I was just reading something
where it said
that "Avatar" is the highest
grossing film of all time,
and then it got beat out
by "Avengers,"
and that was
the #1 highest grossing,
but then "Avatar" became again
the highest grossing film.
Do you care about that stuff,
or you don't care?
-Well, look, I mean, everybody
makes a big deal out of it,
but the truth is
what we really need to focus on
is getting back to theaters.
And, you know, hopefully, we can
still have films like that,
like "Endgame" and "Avatar," the
big Marvel movies and all that
that are able to make, you know,
$1 billion or $2 billion.
Let's pray that the theaters
are there after this pandemic
and after this shift
toward streaming --
not that I have anything
against streaming.
There's great writing,
great shows.
But let's remember
that the movie theater
is kind of a sacred experience
for all of us.
And let's get back out there
when it's safe to do so.
-Yeah, let's get to -- I agree.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think people will go.
So, now this project
that you're working on,
"The Secrets of the Whales."
-Mm-hmm.
-You get so up-close
and personal with --
It's the most beautiful shots.
I mean, obviously, if anyone
ever saw a whale ever, it is --
You talk about it for months,
I mean, maybe years.
You go, "I saw a whale!" And --
No, you've never seen a whale
like this.
This is unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-What is the feeling you want
people to get from this special?
-Yeah, just want to --
Full disclosure,
I wasn't in the water
with the whales on this show.
I've done that other times.
-Right.
-But we had Brian Skerry
and some of the top, you know,
underwater photographers
at National Geographic.
And I'm an explorer
in residence there,
which is kind of an oxymoron.
But I know all those guys.
So we cooked this thing up
about three years ago.
It's taken three years to shoot,
24 locations around the world.
The idea was what are we going
to show about whales
that hasn't been seen
and that hasn't been known?
So the goal was find out
new things, see new things,
also do amazingly
beautiful photography.
But we found out that they --
They have culture.
They have emotion. They grieve.
They have joy. They play.
They have complex language.
They have music.
They have family bonds.
They teach each other.
They have taught culture
that's handed down.
And they're very, very complex
and amazing animals.
They're not just big
and beautiful and kind of,
you know, mysterious
and awe-inspiring.
They're people.
They're basically people.
I think, if anybody should
get a takeaway from this show,
it's that whales are people
just like us.
And they're trying
to survive out there.
They're trying to keep
their families fed and healthy,
and hopefully, the show can
create some kind of a bond,
a compassionate bond with them.
-Yeah.
-'Cause we have to protect them.
We have to help them survive.
-Yeah. Good for you. I agree.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a very unique moment
captured in "Secrets
of the Whales." Take a look.
-This one female
adult orca came in
and, you know, was sort of
checking me out.
♪♪
It was kind of looking at me,
checking out the ray.
It was kind of like, you know,
"Are you going to have that?
'Cause if not,
I'm going to go grab it."
♪♪
And then just sort of picks it
up and almost poses, man.
She just kind of
lifts her head up.
It was really remarkable.
-Yeah. That's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Isn't that cool?
-That is really cool.
-So, this mother orca says,
"You look skinny.
You should eat.
Here, have something."
-Yeah, yeah. "Eat, eat!"
Yeah, of course, exactly.
-"You're not going to eat that?
Alright, I'm taking it back."
-James Cameron, everybody.